Selena Gomez opened up about why she was
laying low this summer revealing she
underwent a kidney transplant for her
lupus I want them to know it's okay I
was okay with dealing with it but an
even more shocking revelation her
longtime friend acted as the donor for
this surgery surround yourself with the
greatest girls on Thursday the good for
you singer shared a throwback snap from
their hospital beds she captioned a
quote there aren't words to describe how
I can possibly thank my beautiful friend
Francie Ariza adding she gave me the
ultimate gift and sacrifice so who is
Selena's BFF here's what you need to
know I'm joining my life and I'm getting
to do things that I'm passionate about
with the people that I love Francia is a
29 year old actress known for her role
as Adrienne on The Secret Life of the
American teenager she's also set to star
as a series regular on the new blackish
spin-off grown --is-- Selena and Francia
have been besties for nearly a decade
now CMO from celebrating their birthdays
a year after year to getting their dance
on and choreography class might we add
Francia has some killer dance moves and
nothing says friendship goals like girls
trips and chowing down on hot wings
together Selena and her gal pal appeared
to be inseparable and major soul sisters
[Music]